-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
yesterday was the first Sunday
of the football season,
and, yeah, it was good.
You know, after eating
and drinking for 11 hours,
I think I speak for
all Americans when I say,
forget Labor Day.
This is the Monday
we needed off.
Don't you think?
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is Monday -- Wow.
That's right, yesterday was the
first Sunday of the NFL season.
Yeah, there were 14 games and
400 commercials for DraftKings.
Yeah, there were so
many DraftKings commercials,
the guy who got the most
play time was Kevin Hart.
But this was exciting.
History was made last night
as 45-year-Old Tom Brady became
the oldest starting quarterback
in NFL history.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, at Brady's age,
when he claps to get the snap,
all the lights
in his house turn off.
You can tell
Brady's getting up there
'cause he has to put
tiny tennis balls
at the bottom of each cleat.
Yeah, at Brady's age,
the only false start he gets now
is when he's peeing.
Look, guys, it was the first
NFL weekend of the year,
and DirecTV's NFL Sunday Ticket
website and app crashed.
Fans were upset, and many
complained that customer service
wasn't helpful either.
Listen to this call.
I think you'll see why.
[ Dial tone ]
"Jiggle the dish"?
"Jiggle the dish.
Jiggle the dish."
Meanwhile, in other sports news,
the Cleveland Guardians were
playing the
Minnesota Twins, right?
And at one point,
the umpire checked the
Guardians' pitcher
for a banned substance
known as "sticky stuff."
Sticky stuff.
And his search
was pretty thorough.
This is real.
Take a look at this.
-Well, it's one of those things
where you have a guy
that goes to the hair so much.
-What?!
[ Laughter ]
That's a bit much.
-Wow.
And who says baseball
can't compete with football?
You know what I'm saying?
With that...
The umpire looked like
he was a judge at
the Westminster Dog Show.
Did you guys see this?
Today, President Biden was
in Boston delivering remarks on
the infrastructure law,
and then he started talking
about airports
and he got pretty fired up.
Watch this.
-Today, not a single, solitary
American airport --
not one -- ranks in
the top 25 in the world.
The United States of America --
not one airport ranks in
the top 25 in the world.
What in the hell's
the matter with us?
-Whoa!
-Wow!
What?
Wow!
-That's comin' in hot
for Grandpa Joe.
-Yeah, yeah. Right?
Then they called
his boarding group,
and Biden was like, "Never mind.
Everything's fine.
Alright, we're all..."
Hey, there's a new book
coming out about
former President Trump,
and it sounds like
during his final days in office,
he was thinking about
refusing to leave.
Listen to this.
-Trump repeatedly told aides
following his election loss that
he would refuse to leave
The White House.
Trump quizzed
nearly everyone around him
on how to stay in power.
Among those he reportedly asked,
the valet who bought him
Diet Coke when Trump
pressed a red button
on his Oval Office desk.
[ Laughter ]
-And if all else fails,
Trump was going to keep
kicking his feet so staffers
couldn't put on his shoes.
He's like, "I'm not leaving.
I'm not leaving."
Speaking of Trump,
apparently the former president
wants the government to help pay
for a special master
to review the seized
Mar-a-Lago documents,
but the Justice Department
wants Trump to pay for it.
Great. Now they have to
agree on a special master
to decide who has
to pay for the special master.
Well, I saw that,
this weekend, King Charles
was participating
in a ceremony to mark
his official rise to the throne,
and there was a moment where
he got a little testy over some
extra pens on his desk.
Watch this.
-Noting that the king
is signing "Charles Rex."
[ Laughter ]
-Every staffer was like,
"Well, this is gonna be
a super-fun change.
Wow."
Get this -- people on the inside
are saying Charles
is already dealing with
quite a few problems.
For example, I heard that he
can't decide what to do with
all the palaces left to him
by his mother.
Kings -- they're just like
the rest of us.
Apparently, his first order
of business was
really stretching the definition
of the word "problem."
It's definitely going to be
weird seeing Charles pop up
on an episode of
"Love It or List It."
Meanwhile, I read that all of
Queen Elizabeth's corgis
are now going to live with
Prince Andrew.
[ Audience "Awws, laughter ]
In response,
one of the corgis said...
And finally, before we go on,
I'd like to take a moment
to thank some of our sponsors
for tonight's show.
They don't always fit
in the commercial breaks,
and we always want to make sure
that we mention all of them.
It is time for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show Sponsors" ♪
♪ "Tonight Show Sponsors" ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Huh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And finally...
That's all for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."
We have a great show.